my name is kaine i work at microsoft
research in their biological computation
group
so i'm going to talk about cells they're
real biology cells but i'm a software
guy so the only real difference is that
rather than machine code that comes out
my compiler generates dna
so other than that it's not that
different now
cells are often kind of referred to as
like the building block of life and
they're kind of natural units in biology
and if we can work out how to program
them effectively as we do with digital
computers
there's a lot of breakthroughs we can
make in terms of medical technology
and clean energy and sustainable
agriculture
it's also just kind of interesting
hacking on living systems and kind of
figuring out what they can do
so there's been quite a lot of talk in
industry about biologically inspired
computing so taking ideas from
the biological world in terms of
self-healing systems
genetic algorithms and i think last year
jeff hawkins was talking here some of
you may have seen
like computing like the brain so what
i'm going to be talking about is the
opposite side of that process so taking
ideas from computing
and putting them into biology and how
the kind of processes we use as software
engineers can be helpful for the
biologists as well
so some of the examples of the kind of
things are like formal methods and state
management
and there's a quite cool recent
development this year from drewendy
at stanford university where they
developed what they referred to the
transcriptor
which is a direct analog from the
electric transistor
so what you use it for is controlling
the flow of biological computation
but in a biological setting so
i don't know if some of you might have
been in the hardware hacking workshop
yesterday i mean what our real vision is
if we can download
bits of biological code from the
internet drag them onto some kind of
software environment
and then boot it up like just like
you're booting up an arduino that's what
we'd like to be able to do
so there's three scales that we're
interested in working on
so there's a cellular level which is the
natural area and then there's
below that there's molecules how it's
built up and we also do some work on
cell colonies depending on how many
questions i might skip the last section
so what we want to do in each of the
cases though is have deliberate control
so design the system we want to build
simulate it
and be confident that when we go to the
wet lab it's probably going to work
whereas at the moment it's more like
it's probably not going to work
so this is the kind of software we'd
like to build the kind of
cad so kind of equivalent the automotive
and engineers generally have
so i'm just going to talk a little bit
about the
what we've got to work with so this is a
dna strand
and it's made up of a series of letters
so there's gc
tna and they go in pairs so you always
get a g and a c together and you always
get a tna together
they can be flipped around in both
directions so rather than binary's two
states
you have four different states and
it's not just the language that gets
read like a programming code it's also
got definitions
of the language itself so you can kind
of think of
dna in some ways a bit like a virtual
machine image that you just
add some water and then you're good to
go it's you don't need to kind of
external definition of what's happening
so how do we work with this stuff so you
have
the dna codes or letters and there's a
special kind of protein called a
polymerase
and this transforms a part of the
dna code into a strand and then we
transform this strand into what's called
messenger rna
so on the left you can see the
polymerase traveling along the dna and
this is this is about 20 base per second
so it's chugging along doing the
translation after that the messenger rna
is translated into a chain of
amino acids by a special protein called
a ribosome
here we can see like the chain of amino
acids coming out of the ribosome
and once the chain comes out it folds
into the protein structure
so what we've got is kind of a situation
of proteins acting on dna producing more
proteins that act on the other proteins
i hadn't really explained what a protein
is so this is
a bigger kind of protein so the protein
is the one on the left and it's quite a
large one it's an enzyme
and so it's got thousands of atoms and
the structure on the right hand side
is the substrate that it's working upon
now i'm not sure i've heard from a lot
of people like it's one of their
ambitions when they're coming to
strangely to actually read
uh gerald barkesha and there's a really
good chapter in there so if anybody has
managed to get as far as chapter 16
you're kind of well prepared for the
talk
and if you haven't and you're confused
at all you should go and read that to
get some more clues so i mean it's it's
quite an old book but a lot of the
essential ideas have kind of
uh survived the test of time the only
kind of things that
happened in practice seem to be it's got
more entangled so there's
more deeply nested and tangled
hierarchies so those proteins
also affect the dna so you've got this
kind of circular situation where the
proteins now affect the dna which
produces the protein
and it's not clear what's the the
origin of this process but it says
self-rooted loop a bit like a compiler
you have to bootstrap it up and then
keep progressing so
i'm going to talk first about molecular
computing
so it's below the level of the cells so
as well as the other functions the dna
performs then it's
also quite interesting as a chemical
structure so the letters themselves
are
made up of chemical compounds so we're
going to go ahead and like unravel the
helix
so what you have now is two separated
strands
and what's holding them together
is fairly weak hydrogen bonds so
they go across the gap and along the uh
molecule you have along the dna strand
you have strong covalent bonds
so if you
imagine a situation where you chop off a
segment of the dna
you can glue them back together in a
lighter way so the small ones
have relatively few total hydrogen bonds
they form a kind of short helix
it doesn't hold it together that
strongly so you can take those segments
get them together and they'll fall apart
the longer ones will form
at a longer loop and it'll be a stronger
total bond so that'll tend to bind
irreversibly unless you
specially intervene so that's about all
we actually need
for being able to do dna at the
molecular level there's lots of
approaches that need
fairly expensive enzymes but this
approach is kind of sufficient for us
so i'm just going to actually
now talk about some of the the process
that you make use of it so what we've
got along the
top is is a strand of dna and along the
bottom
is the complementary
section of dna so if those two strands
were on their own they'd bind very
tightly but this strand at the bottom
has
some bits bound onto it into the way now
what we've got is
what we refer to as toe hold which is
the short red segment which is an area
where
the dna will because it's short it'll
reversibly bind onto
so you can have situations where the
molecules will naturally move
back and forth and just to clarify
obviously this is dna
these things aren't conscious they're
not making decisions it's something that
happens as kind of stochastic randomized
process
so because it's made a short bond there
it's also able to
push along the middle section that was
tightly bound
so you you can imagine a situation of it
attaching to the dna
and then mush mushing along the other
sections until it
finally knocks off the other segments or
strand of dna
so what we've got a situation here is
we've had one input we pushed another
one and some
kind of difference happened now because
it's there's no none of these toe holds
or short sections left
this this situation is now fairly stable
now that was a kind of arbitrary example
what i wanted to talk about
on the computing side that you you might
be able to imagine a situation where you
want to create a logic gate
so if you have some kind of cancer
marker in a cell
it might be an indicator that there's
some cancerous material there but things
aren't always
certain and you want to be able to make
deductions based on having multiple or
or sufficient quantities of cancer
markers so
what we want to do is try and make a an
and gate in this case
so we can again have the situation where
the input will bind onto on the short
segment
and nudge off the section and you can
also imagine another situation where
it'll bind on at the other end as well
so
these sections in the middle can be
pushed out and then it'll displace the
full output
so if you use this as a chain in the
process of these inputs
indicate something you want to detect in
the cell and that output
will be acted upon by some other part of
the system
later on now it's a bit of a hassle
having to
write out these dna segments all the
time
and you have to make sure they match and
so that's a kind of laborious and
error-prone process
so this is what computing is pretty good
at we give names to things
and then we're able to
i refer to them by those and it's a more
effective process for building systems
and so this is a part of a language at
the bottom that we've developed
and you can use it to program high level
behaviors and scale up higher
so i'm just going to give a bit of a
demonstration of this process using
uh the tool that we built i was going to
can anybody hazard a guess
how you might be able to make an or gate
based on some kind of
function outside this i can go ahead and
show you there's nobody wants to guess
okay
okay i'll just make this big enough so
you're about to see
okay i'll just have to close the
presentation
this is going to be harder
okay sorry for the delay
so
so what i've done here is i've defined
up one part of the species so this is
going to be one input to the system
and then i'm going to define the other
side
so what the syntax means in this case is
the angle brackets
are a strand that moves along the top
the numbers are the labels for sections
of dna
the carrots are indicating that it's a
toe holder or short binding
so what i'm going to do to build an or
gate in the middle
is rather than having two pieces that
need to be displaced there's just one
place that's shared between the two
sides
okay so what we've got a system here is
that the angle bracket
the the curly braces are lower bian
binds
lower strands and the star indicates
that it's the complement so it's the
reverse of the dna strand at the top
so we've got a kind of definition of an
or gate here so what i'll do
is now instantiate a
certain size of the system so what we're
going to do is build
a system with one of a
and one of b
and one of the or gates
and now i'm going to go ahead and try
compiling it c5
excellent so what i've done is built a
system and this is showing
all the kind of intermediate states and
intermediate species
and we it can get quite complicated to
understand these systems at larger
scales
so we've built some visualization tools
for indicating the straight
state transitions so what we want to do
now
is understand whether this system is
actually going to behave the way we want
it to in practice so we've built
a series of simulation tools for
building these things on on the computer
and then
running how they might behave so this
isn't going as far as molecular dynamics
it's a step beyond that but it'll give
us an indicator of whether these things
are going to work in practice
so
we can attempt to simulate this to see
whether it will behave as we want to
and what we end up here is with a lot of
the intermediate species which kind of
gets in the way of seeing what's going
on so
here what i'm going through is the
process of just indicating these are the
only species that we want to see in the
output
and so what we've got is a reducing
amount of
species a and reducing amount of species
b so what we've done in this case is
what's
referred to as a deterministic solution
we've taken the maths and then our
calculations if these things can be
infinitely divided so in the real
biological situation we don't have
things that can be broken apart these
are like our minimum unit sizes
and so another way of analyzing the
situation is a stochastic simulation
which in that situation you imagine
these these bits and they interact and
they transform but you can't divide them
up
and so if i try that sometimes what will
happen is one of them will be
transformed
and not not on the other one so these
things become a lot clearer if we have a
few more of each
so what we've got here is some of the
inputs being transformed
and that
sometimes they'll bind and bind and then
go back to floating
in the super stuff but you are getting
transformations into the output so
we could equally do this kind of
simulation with the and gate
and that would then only work if
the work quantities are reached to be
used up
okay
okay so what i showed you there was a
fairy toy example
and so with lots of the collaborators we
have experimentalists as well as fairy
people
they've taken this approach and
sometimes with that tool itself
and built up chains of these logic gates
the same way kind of electronics
engineer
would use multiple logic gates in order
to provide a function
you can also chain up these sets of
behaviors as well
so one of the more concrete things that
we've done with this is there's a
identity called a dna optima this is
like a little chain that you can make
and you can take it between something
that an organism already knows about
and something that's kind of it's naive
to it hasn't been exposed to it
so an experiment was done where they
took a
pathogen in this case anthrax and
some mice and that the
some pathogens that the mice were
already exposed to
and if you build an aptima that directly
binds between
anthrax and this existing known pathogen
then what you create is a kind of
instant immunity so
the mice could be given as much and
facts as you wanted to
they weren't affected at all so it
wasn't so good for the control case but
so this is another uh more kind of
natural to the
biology sphere so there's this kind of
ongoing debate that
a lot of the engineers are involved in
biology now
they want to make everything into a
logic gate but there's also
a more direct way in some respects of
directly building the analog
decision making process so what we
wanted to do was
build an algorithm that would judge the
majority of this existing nsl
and so you could tell whether there's
more of the bad stuff or more the good
stuff
and then make a determination of whether
you want to do something about that
so what we did was build a kind of
series of chemical reactions
so this is kind of an indirect way of
going about it
where you have to in practice is even
more indirect but what you're doing is
every time an x or y meet they all
combine and turn into some kind of
intermediate molecule
every time an x bumps into this
intermediate molecule
it turns into 2x and every time a y
bumps into an intermediate molecule it
also similarly
turns into 2y
so
the reason this in practice figures out
which is in the highest concentration is
that the probability of an x bumping
into an
immediate molecule is proportional to
the number of x's that all
exist in the system so the more x's
there are the faster it will move in
that direction
so just to kind of give you a like a
little bit of insight into the
process of building more complicated
systems and these are the
strands and processes that we have to
put together to make it
fast enough in a biological system and
also reliable
okay and so as well as wanting to make
these kind of decisions there's also
times when we want to
perform more numerical operations so
things like counting you can do fairly
well in cells and make decisions on that
but people also want to do things like
calculate square roots and so
this uh fairly long uh series of strands
which
you can probably make out somewhat is
one implementation
of a square root circuit implemented in
molecular
computing so kind of question is like is
this correct
and so we have good techniques for this
in
uh computing that you can use a fun kind
of formal methods approach
so probably a lot of you might have used
like sat solvers and the like
and so one of my colleagues and
collaborators have worked
on applying uh the z3 smt solver to the
biological case
and so i'm not going to tell you over
this one works because they're going to
be announcing probably next week at
a dna conference but
i can say that some some published uh
dna
uh implementations don't work very well
and some work better
okay so
doing the time okay so
i said i was going to talk about cells
so we're going to move up to that level
now
and one people always kind of obsess
about in computing it's like how
powerful your computer is compared to
all the other computers and
who has the most megahertz person like i
mean in lots of ways then cells put
like current computers to shame they're
not so good on the megahertz
but they are massively parallel they're
a bust of failure they
build themselves so you don't have to
have to buy them yourself and
they're also very efficient in terms of
the calculations type of
helm for the amount of energy that you
provide them with
so one of the other nice features is
that they're actually in some instances
quite cross-platform you can take the
dna out of the jellyfish
and transplant it move it into a
bacteria and
it still goes so that the function that
represented the glowing capacity
in jellyfish is general enough that it
can work across species there's lots of
things that don't work this way and it's
hard to
translate them across so you're not
going to be able to get dna and just
glow for parties or anything like that
well you probably wouldn't want to risk
it either but now in terms of the
efficiency of storage then this is quite
interesting paper
where the blue ones are basically our
current technologies these are the
things that the
electronics have been able to make and
the purple color is the kind of
the borderline physics approach and so
on the x-axis
we're kind of indicating how much
we've been able to encode into this
system so things off to the far right we
can
we can put a lot of information there
and to the far left we can put very few
things
and the y scale is how dense it is so
how big the thing is
you have to produce in order to have
that amount of information
so there's some quite interesting work
of encoding
the information you have to store into
those
letters of the dna and so they're quite
good in terms of
amounts of density so you can fit into a
very small area
but they're not really up there yet with
the total amount it's also
a bit expensive at the moment so it's
about ten thousand pounds
ten thousand dollars per megabyte to
write and 200
to read so that's not really gonna be
very appealing to anybody
just yet but one of the very interesting
things there's some quite interesting
trends in economics of
dna reading and writing that in general
then
electronics will move up about a factor
of 1.6 per year
so you'll get that kind of gradual
increase whereas the historical trends
on dna reading and writing are going up
much faster rates between five and ten
fold at times
and so this is kind of one of the areas
i was interested getting when i started
in the field that
like almost nothing moves faster than
moore's law in terms of
software development areas and so
any field where there's trends where the
basic cost of doing things is going down
at a greater rate than moore's law
you can kind of see some disruptive
potential so if you could make something
work now
just about then in a couple of years you
might be on to a very effective
situation
so this kind of suggestions maybe five
ten years it might be
commercially viable to be storing
long-term data storage in dna
so there's also another way of looking
at being able to write
dna that the bigger systems we can build
for a cost-effective manner
then we can build more interesting
systems so this is a guy called rob
carlson that
he's made kind of an analogy between two
quite different things um
there's debate whether it even makes
sense so what we're measuring
is the number of transistors per chip in
blue which is
this is what intel and amd are doing and
in
orange and red that's reading the dna
and it's measured
in a slightly odd measure of bases per
person per day
so it's a person physically doing that
and in yellow it's
writing the dna in a similar basis per
person today
so there's one company that's kind of
kind of going for this process called
amorous
and so what they've built is a kind of
sympathetic biology route
to producing one of the key ingredients
that goes into
malaria treatment so they've got this up
and running rather than
producing artemisial acid through an
agricultural route which is quite
difficult and expensive then they have a
biology reactor type system where
they've taken
dna gone through a design process and
put it into the cells now the problem is
they had to go through a lot of
engineering and research
to get this far and so something they've
kind of publicly said and they work on
themselves is they themselves want a
kind of software process
for being able to do this so
there's expectation and
jay keysling there one of the
co-founders amara said that like in
all internet areas of engineering then
you have
simulation tools the idea that you just
build something and find out if it works
isn't really very effective compared to
being able to follow this rational
process
okay so we still got all these problems
like we're kind of
hacking into these systems because we
didn't write the original uh
code a lot of the time we're trying to
find pieces we want to make use of and
there's all kinds of
challenges that kind of they sound like
to me like the software engineer's kind
of experience as well that you're
you haven't got the present system
working properly but you're still
expected to add more functionality on
top of it
and so having having some tools that can
help you out with that seems like it
would be quite nice
so this is one of the things we've been
doing that
it's a piece of software for expressing
the
behavior of the system and then getting
the process out so i'll just play a
little
bit of the video which is showing the
uh dna transcription process so this is
the polymerase attaching and then it's
going to move down the dna chain and
produce the messenger
rna so it's quite fun video but
move on so this is the current process
we've got a like low level view of dna
that we
have the start
of the dna where we want to bind onto
which is called promoter
and we have the end which is a
terminator so these are sections of the
dna that the
will will move along and do so there's
kind of interesting things that overlaps
and and this is
this is this way of communicating and so
the prong arrays
needs to move along this system and
so what we've had to do in each of these
cases is provide the very specific
elements for these
these parts and it's it's not it's not
it's not helpful because if you move one
part out
then you can cause the rest not to work
and this is in a sense the hello world
of
producing something that it's this isn't
what we want to do we want to produce
far more significant systems and if this
is hard and unpredictable
and making minor changes causes
unexpected
outcomes we haven't got really a hope of
producing bigger systems
so what we want to do is say this is all
i want you to do
fill in the parts for me so what i'm
going to do is another kind of
toy example which this is one of the
very early things in synthetic biology
called the repressor later
and what we've got here is we've got
compound a
and b and c at least that's what i'm
going to say rather than the biology
versions of it
that what happens is that a inhibits b
and b inhibits c and then c inhibits a
so you've got a system where
if you've got a lot of a then that'll
suppress b
which means c is going to go unchecked
and c will then
increase and that'll start suppressing a
so you've got a dynamical system
in practice so another tool
okay so what i'm going to do is skip
ahead to the example
rather than typing it out this time so
this is our
our expression of the system so
we have a coding for a and we have
a promotion against the inhibition of c
so
these are the three different parts of
the system and we've also got
a database of genetic parts and so what
we're going to ask the system to do is
now
solve this for us and it's produced
quite a lot of solutions as you can kind
of see from the comment that
one of them is good and one of those not
so good so
i kind of show you to start off with why
the first one isn't so good
and the way we do this testing in this
case is again with simulation
so
what we've got here is just one part of
the system that's going kind of out of
control there's no
oscillations there's no the other parts
coming into play so what's happened here
is the gymnastic parts aren't really
compatible for the function that we've
described
so rather than going to the lab and
finding this out you can find this out
to an approximation
in silicon so instead if we
pick the better solution
and run the simulation this is always
risky because it's a randomized process
so it could just not work
but that would be very unlikely but
we've got peaks here of the green and
then the red and the blue
and it's not perfect there's like a lot
of noise in the system which is a
fundamental part of it
but it's it's what you deal with in a
biological system so
you'd also need reinforcement and things
like the
approximate majority circuits built on
top of this in order to get
reliable behavior out of the out of the
end
okay
okay and in a kind of similar way that i
kind of showed you a toy example but
these tools are actually used for real
research purposes
this is a model of a part of the immune
system that when a cell in your body
gets infected
then the cells themselves want to
well the cells communicate what's inside
them because
your immune system wants to come around
and inspect what's happening
and so the mechanism for this happening
is the mhc class 1 system
so it takes fragments of the viruses
that might have got inside your cells
or parts of the cells themselves and
move them out to the outside
this is quite involved mechanism
but using uh this same tool we choose
the other example
then we're able to explore how variables
act on this
we're able to collect experimental data
and then train a model that was better
able to predict
a real behavior and so then some of my
colleagues have published work
based on this okay
so the choice is if you've got questions
i can answer questions or i can
talk about cell colonies so i guess an
indication are there lots of burning
questions
so your time access are you actually
how are you simulating time there is it
actually uh based on the
chemical dynamics yes
it is discrete
stepping yep so the x-axis are real
time periods um most of the inputs for
this kind of system they're not set up
for real work
so they're not that the parameters that
are fed in aren't accurate
so therefore the time periods won't be
true if you go and collect
characterization data and then use
machine learning techniques to train the
models
then it would be accurate
so i think i'll keep talking then if we
don't have any any
for your dna questions what are you
assuming for the stabilities of the
different intermediates
because your delta g values for your
products
are marginally marginally stable the
back reactions are going to occur
and i assume you're using that in your
stochastic simulations as well so what
underlying dynamics are
so i'm not familiar with the term delta
g um we have
okay so we have
okay uh so the reactions will will go
back and forth
so the the short sections will bind and
unbind
i mean in terms of i've done if you're
asking questions about molecular
dynamics
or more deep than that
yep
if that reaction isn't stable you're
going to go
and do back reaction as well so in your
model are you assuming 100
completion of the reaction so you have
only products left to go on to the next
stage of the reaction
no you wouldn't necessarily have a full
transformation and it's going to
asymptotically approach
the final state so this is probably why
you have a lot more
involved solutions for real-world
problems that
it won't go close enough and so you'd
have to build more circuitry on top
so a lot of these biological systems
they don't need to reach
the full final state in order to act
you have the things you're trying to
achieve for example
treating medical conditions you only
need to treat a certain number of the
cells
in itself anyway
ah question there what is the mechanism
uh there's some quite helpful companies
that you email them your dna that you
want and they'll fabricate it for you
so slight slightly distressingly
i think they took uh inspiration from
web 2.0 so there's a company called dna
2.0
so there are certain restrictions as you
might imagine that people might have
the dna for something that's somewhat
harmful and you don't necessarily want
people to
order off for dangerous uh biological
material but in general
as long as what you ask for isn't
expected to be dangerous they'll send
you biological samples
from your specification
anymore
okay
so i'm just going to talk briefly
about the uh the cells moving together
so
what we have is things like biofilms
which are colonies of bio
cells which there's a lot of different
types of cells but
together they uh form a
hard to undermine colony and resistant
to antibiotics
so what we've done is on gpus and i
can't give a demo of this
um because this laptop doesn't really
have a good enough
gpu in it that
we're able to predict how these cells
will interact
and carry out experiments and one of
these is to
take a prediction of how much of the
interaction between cells
is caused by their physical shape so
what we've done here
is taken over the situation of rod
shaped shells
rod so elongated cells or just round
cells
and we've stained the different uh
colonies
uh so the original cells that made up
these parts and then
grew them on the computer and so the
purely from the physics of the situation
then there's been penetration into these
different areas so i think that's
just about it so i'm just going to wrap
up now that
so what i've shown was both the dna
computing molecular computing area
and also the kind of forward engineering
of cells
in a term called synthetic biology some
of the things that the
group i work in does is
try to understand rather than engineer
systems so
how the immune system behaves and how
cells develop
and so underlying all of this we have a
kind of shared
library and has a lot of functions for
the
simulation and the analysis of the
system and we can also output
and produce solutions that are based on
this
using external code as well uh and so
this is the group i work with so there's
a lot of researchers and
i've shamelessly stolen lots of their
work and put it in here so i'm very
grateful to them
and i'll just leave you with some other
things that we're
kind of working on okay